william ruto has been declared the
winner of kenya's presidential election
he won 55 of the vote
50.5 percent of the vote narrowly
beating his rival raila odinga speaking
at his victory rally reuters said that
he would be a leader for all kenyans no
matter which way they voted in the
election the announcement was delayed
there were scuffles and allegations of
vote rigging by mr odinga's campaign and
four out of seven electoral
commissioners said they could not
support the outcome saying it was opaque
people have been celebrating for hours
here in kisumu western kenya they are
confident their favorite candidate raila
odinga will soon be named kenya's next
president
kisumu is the stronghold of long-time
veteran opposition leader odinga we're
waiting for our fifth president that is
i believe and i highly hoping that he
will be right
from there
but then after a three-hour delay the
final result was officially declared
of the independent electoral boundaries
commission
[Applause]
hereby declares that
router william samoy
has been duly elected as the president
in other parts of the country william
ruto supporters celebrated the
announcement
the mood in kisumu changed rapidly
they are disappointed they expected ryla
odinga to win
[Applause]
they say their victory has been stolen
street battles lasted for two hours
protesters threw stones at police
reacted by firing tear gas the police
has managed to actually push back the
protesters down this road we've heard
that some shops have been looted
we also hear occasional gun fire the
police are still patrolling the roads
and makes sure that the situation
remains calm overnight
meanwhile president-elect william ruto
addressed the country
i want to promise the people of kenya
that
i will run a transparent open
democratic government
[Applause]
and i will work with the opposition to
the extent
that they provide oversight
over my administration
even though a large part of the country
remains a laboratory and peaceful it
will be one of william ruto's hardest
tasks to reconcile a divided country
[Applause]
[Music]
dw's felix moringa is following events
in the kenyan capital nairobi felix even
as the results were announced scaffolds
broke out at the election commission
does this set the tone for the coming
days
good morning so whatever happened
yesterday does not set the tone for the
next coming days but
as
you've rightfully said a scaffold broke
the country is uh
is on there
is is on a divided path because
up to over 6.8 million people who voted
for raila are 6.9 million rather people
who voted for ayla odinga feel
aggravated by the result that was
released yesterday but on the other hand
the 7.1 million people who voted for
william ruto are in a celebratory mood
but
we had yesterday william ruto say that
his government will be a government for
all and as much as he has promised to
run a transparent
government
some of the electoral commission
commissioners said that the process that
brought him to office was an opaque
process and they will be giving evidence
in the course of days but something uh
that will be happening later today is
that
the azimi leader raila odinga will be
giving an address and that will
determine
the next course of action for for the
country in the in the coming days
now in his first speech the
president-elect promised to work with
the opposition the question is will the
opposition work with him and what are
his key priorities
so uh on whether the opposition will
work with him or not again that's that's
that's a case of wait and see because
it's dependent on the opposition to
decide whether they want to work with
him or disapprove of his presidency but
some of the key priorities in the
country right now is the high cost of
living kenyans want that
now that president ruto has come to
office that he can look at the cost of
living which has forced many of kenyans
to sleep on empty stomachs again there
is very high unemployment among the
young people and young people are hoping
that william ruto can be
that bullet that changes the whole
dynamics something else that kenya has
been grappling with is high debt
that has threatened
the public coffers so kenyans are also
hoping that with william ruto's
presidency he promised during his
campaigns that he will stop digging he
will stop taking further debt and he
will
bring in mechanisms to ensure that kenya
was not going further down into the debt
burden and so kenyans will be keen to
see how he handles the debt burden
felix maringa there reporting from
nairobi thank you felix